hello everyone it's 8:30 a.m. in the
morning
and what's let's play a nice hyperbola
tournament hopefully hopefully the plan
is to get into top three but we'll see
how it goes okay
that's just very nice let's go back here
not alone any tricks capture capture
let's go here that's like really really
trying really trying to trick me free
moving I guess I push
there's many queens as possible okay
good job good job we managed to win that
one against the cork sucker okay let's
go [ __ ]
okay fine yes I know you remove that
it's hyperbolic after all but so did I
oh man corpse sucker is really fast and
I really wonder everything with free
moves
I don't really have a plan here my plan
Oh managed to trick him but but that's
hyper bullet for you okay let's let's
try and since those pre moves I have to
I have to sense them so I'm gonna play a
five no matter what it plays all that
leftover leftover is it love or war I
don't think yeah she decided not to play
this game
okay still then still hanging in there
although this was a this was a free wind
okay
minnak 87 let's go capture let's go look
you want okay capture capture mission b3
whoa already going for checkmate
that's nasty that's nest let's go here
capture here capture here we have three
capture here go back
oh yes sir
I guess I push seems like a reasonable
plan yeah push push push
okay I I don't believe this I mean my
mouse was literally not moving that's
just that's that's the joy of hyper
bullet it's not all about the moves okay
I have to have to play faster
let's go here that's that's allowing me
to trickin okay I don't really mind
admission wage five six I know say that
capture capture here I guess Wow I mean
wow okay it's very interested in playing
fast so this might be my chance
right again okay we're against hangers
and he will berserk okay I don't really
mind
I don't think 15 seconds is enough
although it might be if you play like me
let's just capture that to capture
capture capture just go play here like
this trick mated so fast okay actually
spent 15 seconds myself she's still
hanging in there sixth place 19 more
minutes
[Music]
gotta leave yeah okay we're up against
Olivia let's try some 94 like this here
okay
I will do it d2 that's free Queen I
guess but you know that means nothing
Oh Queens and your queen since I'm
already here who's gonna push it let's
go here stop him from escaping and
checkmate him ok game sir
good game sir okay we managed to climb
up the fourth place
let's stay there since we have our flame
it would be very nice to win a couple of
more games flower on the flame but here
comes Hawaii okay
it's probably gonna play very fast so
I'm gonna try and fly fast myself
capture capture okay I have to play h3
and now he wants to capture here what a
sneaky dude
okay you can give it up like this sure I
will take that action sure again okay
game boy managed to defeat way again
break his flame but still 17 minutes and
there's a video master SLM ctk coming
for all of us so it's gonna be
interesting
okay let's try a five probably gonna see
some Primos capture lucky one in that I
guess capture capture capture look here
back here so here rid of Bishop f5 c6 e
8b 6
ok good for captured captured and then
grabbed my phone but he decided not to
do it
ah that was so bad I realized I had only
one second and didn't know I knew I
wouldn't have time okay yes I mean why
not why not
oh yeah that's that's the way to do it a
long time
to make some room for the for the King
first could have captured the night that
was really silly okay I guess I'm Cassie
[Music]
nice capture capture here just not III
man oh very dense okay FM slim stick
let's go let's go mr. FM slim stick some
good theory here I was three seconds for
Queen d1 okay I was gonna be four b-58
for trying to push as much as we can
oh here chef sure I guess ah he saw
through me snake he saw through me here
captures captures captures I am done
whoa
he had the bishop there Dan I thought I
stopped looking I thought it was a draw
oh how did that Bishop get there oh good
game mr. ethem slapstick good game
capture capture that for I know it was
very sneaky of me I guess d5 is an idea
what am i doing I mean I'm getting a
piece either way but I love them some
counter play now okay
good game okay still hanging in there 12
minutes to go Oh Iggy
oh yeah and slam slam Tech FM slimthick
or top three okay what do we go for
let's go again for something like this
just a bit faster change it but I will
Oh what sing
well I guess I should have done done
that differently six capture here and no
I do have i got nothing i got the time
that's when i got okay fourth place
still no stop three or gaining points
really fast
oh yeah i think oh yeah is in the first
place so let's let's try and play a good
game
let's chicken I play c4 capture capture
and castle I do like my center that's
for sure Oh capture here and develop the
night probably a 3 B 4 C 5 capture
capture I don't really wanna change
capture capture go here how do I miss
such Rose is the checkmate I think he
had I think he just misses checkmate
Oh oh that's a shame
best fast stuff okay yeah I was forget
what's the idea here don't really think
there is one I think I messed up the
openings here
oh sure
[Music]
okay she doesn't want to go into
opposite colored bishops and why would
he have to make some moves and some
really long time again a very fast push
too fast okay we have seventh place and
seven minutes to go okay let's let's win
some games that's that's okay
she's pretty moving so fast he might
blunder like this
so yeah that's unfortunate that's this
is the weirdest game I ever played
okay sixth place fool you know you never
know if I catch my flame might get might
let get near the top three okay seven
minutes that's like maybe enough for
seven games
caPSURE yes oh you thought I wasn't
gonna play that just have to play faster
now cuz he's gonna start playing faster
as he's known east so any movies a good
move
just push just push and that is it whoa
free phone other free phone a lot of
free phones although I don't have any
idea I guess Bush I'm still gonna lose
this sometime
or not
okay one more game one more game and we
get the flame but we did spend almost
two minutes for that one game so yeah
one more game for the flame against
Chirag
yeah there aren't any tricks involved
here let's go before just the fur as the
queen capture f4 we know three it's
bullsh b5 what's trying to get our
Knights to cover f5 overlap and go here
I will capture that sure
sure thing okay yes have that chick but
I can play this capture capture eight
eight five she does have a capture but
again okay very nice nice sir okay
I think we got this
well I think that was our last chance to
get somewhere close to the top three but
that's still time for two more games I
guess Asuka Nakamura
really
yes yes remove something
[Music]
oh I mean I actually pull that off in
again with the time yeah it's very
intense
[Music]
totally miss everything
now let's attack with the king a three
fish up here
c5 captured capture the bishop oh I
think there will be time for okay chance
against the rematch against gorilla
what what what can I do like a nice
night I guess
yeah she saw through me snake Oh
beautiful
okay ninth place well good game new game
everyone
well that's it you know had my morning
coffee and enjoyed some hyper bullet so
I'll see you see you guys with some wood
maybe some better hyper bullet next time
I think all for watching and I will see
you soon